Wilbur and Orville Wright the first men
in the history of the world to pilot a
heavier than aircraft in sustained
flight under power and control the
Wright brothers were great pioneers in
the way they approach the problem of
flight the speed about 40 miles an hour
altitude as you see about that
mid-flight 100 feet there are a lot of
different ideas about what an airplane
should look like and what the wings
should look like but there's not all
that much data out there they combined
empirical studies in a wind tunnel with
the actual desire to build an airplane
and learn how to fly it MIT brings that
combination to the next level to really
build the tools build the instruments
take the data compare it to the physical
principles and understand what you're
doing
what we have done is largely focused on
the software challenges what are the
algorithms that allow different kinds of
sensor information to brought together
and fused into a consistent estimate of
where the vehicle is and what's around
it
how do you plan trajectories through the
environment that are safe that a lot of
the vehicle to move quickly without
collision how do you incorporate
information about what's in the world
how do you incorporate sensor
information that tells you what's
changing and how should the vehicle
construct new plans in order to react to
that new information
smaller vehicles are just gonna become
part of our everyday existence they're
going to be a new source of information
about the world and they're going to be
a new way to move things around and
we're just going to take it for granted
100 years from now aeronautical
engineering is a funny kind of
engineering because it's a really a kind
of systems discipline from the beginning
there is the systems problem of how do
you integrate these vehicles safely how
do you integrate these because reliably
how did they do all the things they need
to do without getting in each other's
way I mean that's a huge research
problem that's gonna take many years to
solve and I think there's an opportunity
for us as a department to really be part
of the solution
airplanes are the glue that knit the
global system together but the focus is
on making them more efficient on making
the system more efficient making it more
environmentally friendly
the idea was design an airplane that
could save 70% of you if you think about
a fuselage it's one single bubble and
this one is two bubbles so the fuselage
is wider it lifts more even the Wright
brothers are the winter because you want
to know what's happening is this
airplane actually flying is it going to
lift off is it not and then you want to
be able to change things in the
controlled environment all right turn it
on so I'm gonna go first beer and then
second gear the tunnel is blowing a
hundred miles per hour on the model
we're actually having a big
computational effort and they're
actually simulating exactly the
conditions were running in the tunnel
so you can validate things but the
computations and then the computations
can do much more than you could do
because your turn is limited in speed or
whatnot but their competitions isn't so
I think it experiments wind tunnels
computations you can make an opera
another start at zero idle hold for two
minutes could be okay
increase power to 4,500 mi t--'s model
for a research university has always
been that the best way to educate
students is get them involved in the
research okay speed is off trying down
the tunnel I still you have a bet with a
friend that this thing is gonna fly it
within the next 20 years
each person in this department has some
kind of drive within them some kind of
problem that they want to solve the
spears project is one of the really cool
projects in the Space Systems lab they
actually have satellites inside the ISS
that they can control and send different
algorithms to to improve the way that we
design satellites and operate with the
astronauts like Gregg and Katie I
studied science math and engineering at
MIT and has taken me on a wonderful path
of discovery and adventure the main
strength of the camera its people its
faculty its students its industrial
partners its alumni it's really the
community we have been fortunate to be
able to create you're gonna go a lot
faster if you go straight as opposed to
if you're zigzagging so control is those
is really the what makes or breaks this
competition the best part of each and
every day that I have here is meeting
with my students working through
research problems we are incredibly
fortunate unlikely to have the best
students in the world it's the people
around you that definitely keep you
going and that's one of the main things
I love about this department it's really
very humbling to see what people before
us have done MIT at best known for the
scientists and engineers who had studied
there it started with a vision but then
we had been tremendously fortunate to
attract the people we've been able to
attract whether this Hunsaker Doolittle
Draper commanders individuals who've
made major advances
this kind of basic research into control
and estimation sensing etc has been a
part of our departments history for many
many years the instrumentation lab
Draper the Apollo missions were all
things that came out of this department
and it's great to be continuing that
tradition we've been fortunate to
graduate a large number of astronauts
whether it is Apollo or a space shuttle
it's something that happened we do not
have a deliberate attempt to really
attract astronauts per se I think this
is a byproduct of the way with the
research and the way we do our work
still to this day if young people say
what do I have to do to become an
astronaut go get a PhD at MIT is a
pretty common answer though here people
in this department at MIT in aero-astro
particular they're very excited about
what it is who gets to go to the moon
who gets to launch a rocket right best
to design the next airplane and I think
that's what you have to do and that you
have to do what you like people do it
because it was their dream so we're
trying to enable astronaut performance
on the Moon or Mars get back to the
planet and it's kind of extreme we're
really gonna be going up very steep
terrain we're gonna be going down
looking at craters how can we design
spacesuits and life support systems to
enable that exploration
the current traditional spaces are big
guests pressurized balloons
they're very immobilize and say no no we
want a 20 kilo in an order of magnitude
reduction in mass for sure as well as
maximizing the mobility if I'm gonna
design a suit that applies pressure
directly over your skin essentially I'd
like it to be a second skin that's
that's the real research question how
can I make a second skin we need to
apply a third of an atmosphere so our
design goals 30 kilo Pascal's that's the
same pressurization of the gas
pressurized suit so we're trying to
match the current system but now get rid
of the gas get rid of the balloon put
the pressure directly on the skin and we
think this patterning is really
important I like to describe it lots of
times as a smart zipper so yeah you know
you dawn this you put it on it's
comfortable but maybe a little bit loose
and if you apply then the active
materials and it shrinks it up to get to
our desired pressure State they've
generated actually a lot a lot of force
when they're activated
this is just seamless steel wire but now
imagine this was the shape memory alloys
that we just played around with so if I
open this up can I give you a couple
extra centimeters here to dawn you know
to jump into right rather than me doing
it mechanically being the shape memory
alloy when it's activated under the
voltage or the heat it cinches it up
space is not quite the technological
frontier it was in the 50s where it was
a bit of a wild west the challenges that
were left with in space are really very
hard challenges and they may not be
solved by new inventions they may be
solved by kind of some n runs around
some of the difficult problems I think
in 60 years will have been on Mars
becoming a multi-planet species getting
out of the cradle of Earth permanently
soon we may over populate the earth we
may actually need to look outward we're
gonna be able to point up at skies in
our local neighborhood and say there are
water worlds they are there and there is
there intelligent life on them how do we
communicate with them and how we're
gonna get there
we're gonna have a lot of intelligent
systems in the future and more
automation and more intelligent
automation archeology is like you know
discovering more about our past and
understanding of where we've been and I
kind of Ciera Astros like understanding
of where we can go
you
you